Country Right now with all of you are on
the front end of it because the rest of
the world is trying to catch up right
now and the fact that you guys are here,
it shows that you saw at first and uh,
you were in for a treat for
the next hour and a half,
so everybody give it up for Dr. Jordan.
Thank you.
I'm going to walk through.
I'm going to try to get
through all the rules.
I don't think I've met him
once in London,
but I'm going to give you the background
because there's two other things going
on in my life right now that I'm trying
to sort out and I want to tie them
together and use this,
this chance to talk with you further.
Thinking on,
on all of these fronts simultaneously
I got invited a week and a half to do
something that was really
an overwhelming honor to me.
Um,
the pain with penguin books and in the
UK is putting on the 50th anniversary
version of that.
Thanks.
I think it's hard to say.
No.
You can say.
Well,
I think that's the most important in
the 20th century and maybe it's not,
but it's in the top 10 and we have an
overwhelming impact on me and I want to
use the opportunity to write
that introduction to do
something that needs to be
done.
Um,
I was just in a debate on Saturday
in Toronto called the debates and
debate.
Opponents to contend with was
the idea that just as the,
as the radical right can go too far,
that's a claim of both,
which is virtually no disagreement
except of course from the radical right.
A left and go far and historical evidence
for that is called overwhelming is to
say almost nothing.
And one of the things I challenged
my opponents to do was to say,
well,
how do you know when the
radical left goes too far?
Because they can go too far.
You know,
one debate,
Michael Dyson,
he didn't answer the question at all.
There's not that he was
compelled to or anything.
It was up to him.
And the other one said,
well,
you know,
when they become violent,
which to me is no answer golf because to
say that people have gone too far when
they've gone too far,
isn't helpful
for all of us civilized people assuming
that that's what we are are against
violence.
So it's not a very deep,
it's not a very deep analysis.
But the problem is that trying to figure
out putting the radical left is going
to far is actually extraordinary,
extraordinarily difficult because there
isn't something that appears to be a
smoking pistol.
You know,
when the radical right starts speaking
claims of racial ethnic superiority and
then starts to react
those up in the world.
You think,
okay,
well you guys are out
with the game like that.
That's not acceptable.
You want in the domain of civilized
dialogue anymore on the lab.
It's not so obvious when
things go off the rails.
You know,
and one of the things that really
like reading about reading the Gulag
archipelago,
I liked reading it because it's
not going to do like to read.
It's slick.
The 1700 page scream of anguish,
you know,
it's tense,
tense.
But what Social India and I don't,
I think it was something that no one had
really done before him was to lay out
the evidence that the absolute
brutality of the Soviet Union was not an
aberration in relationship
to Marxist thinking,
but a necessary consequence
of Marxist thinking.
But the problem of course is that the
argument spans something like 1700 pages
and that's not concise and I'm not
criticizing you because of that,
because
because everything in that book needs to
be in there as far as I can tell to in
the world to survive because there's
things you have to eat and just sit there.
You die
in the world,
and even if you don't die,
we can just sit there and
you're going to suffer.
And so the antidote to
suffering in the world,
exactly what you're trying to do.
When you act in the world,
you're a preacher,
you're a 50 year particular physiology
reflects that extraordinary.
What you're trying to
do in the world is to,
is to make things better than they are.
When you're hungry,
to try to feed yourself,
find some uranium.
You're taking care of your
family so they don't suffer.
You're,
you're,
you're orienting yourself
towards something about and
so the first proposition
is you limited world.
Your frame of reference is valiantly.
Essentially what you're doing is moving
always from a place that isn't as good
as it could be to a place that someone
edit and you see the world through that
Lens.
You're at point a and you're going to
point B and point B is better than point a
and so because if it wasn't for
why would you bother with it?
Why would you put in the time and effort
if what you're moving towards is better
than what you have?
It's a matter of definition.
Even that if you're
acting for words a damn,
unless you've decided
to make things worse,
and sometimes people do.
If you're acting towards it and you're
acting out the proposition that what
you're acting towards is bending with
what you have and so there's no escaping.
The world is valued.
Proposition number one and this
proposition number two would be there's no
escaping the social world,
so if you act other value proposition,
you're going to do it socially
because you're surrounded by people.
You're not.
No Man is an island as they say,
and so if you've worked out the
proposition that one thing is better than
another,
it's going to do that with other people
and you're going to cooperate with them
and compete with them in
relationship to that endeavor.
If you go to law school,
some people are better
at school than others.
You go to the source therapist and some
people have a natural talent for that.
It's like so,
so what that means essentially,
and I think this is a universal truth.
I think that as soon as you implement
the value structure in a social situation
and produced a hierarchy,
and I think that we know that,
I think that's respected and phenomena
like the freedom distribution and price
law,
that you formulate a hierarchy.
Some people are better at whatever the
hierarchy is than others and most people
start to stack up at the boss so
you get disproportionate success.
At the top along of minority,
and that's a well established,
that's bookmarks,
absurd.
Even though he made a specific case of it,
he said,
well,
pretend to accumulate the hands of fewer,
fewer people.
He met the same people across time and
he thought it was only wealth as far as I
can tell,
and
and they made a number of other mistakes
at all over talking to at the moment.
So okay,
so you have to act out value in the world
and if you do so you're gonna produce
a higher in a new producer,
higher you can produce winners and losers
and that actually is a problem because
of this electric of it has been.
It's actually quite painful than
your hierarchy is pretty inclusive,
especially if they really lose
because if you lose the now,
if you're way down to zero,
then if you don't have enough to eat,
you don't have medical care
like it gets painful happened.
It's happened.
Not because it's logically appropriate.
Anyways,
so hard about that for a long time with
our higher is because what it means is
that
the reality that we face isn't
the reality of a hierarchy.
It's the set of possible
and the rules that govern operation
in a reality that consists of a set of
higher piece aren't the same rules
that govern success in a hierarchy.
So I can give you a quick example of that.
So imagine you have a child
who's playing the game.
Soccer,
let's say,
um,
for fucking,
since it's Boston Canadian.
No,
your kids play hockey and we'd
have Easter Gospel clarity,
but he's a little stingy with poc and uh,
and you know,
he plays a game.
You and he comes off the
ice and they lose and,
and stick down at the Smith has
a little temper tantrum and uh,
you know,
you,
you have some sense.
So you take them aside and say,
look,
it doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it's how you play the games.
And he's not happy to hear that because
you kind of have a bit of a pout and he
looks at you like there's something wrong
with you and he doesn't know what you
mean because of course he's trying to
win and you probably encouraged him to
win.
And so when you come out and say,
well,
the win or a how you play the game,
he doesn't know what you mean.
And then when he asked you what
do you mean you don't know,
you don't always make your own rules
predictory across the set of all possible
hierarchy,
but the rules were within one higher.
And what you're basically telling your
job is don't sacrifice the manner in
which you would behave when the set of
possible games for victory won your game.
And that's because black
isn't a hockey game.
It's also not a series of kids.
It's more like a series of
hockey games than like one day.
But life is a series of hierarchies,
a series of games.
And you might say,
well how do you win a series of games?
And one answer to that is you get
invited to play a lot of them.
Anybody that does that,
there's an almost an indefinite number
of ways of interpreting the world.
And then that's kind of
split the postmodernism,
say the 1966.
But how do you know how you
should interpret a book?
Fiction.
There's plenty ways to interpret a
piece of fiction after our people.
Well,
how many stable way of interpreting and
if there's no stable way of interpreting
it,
well,
how do you rank our per patient?
How do you know what interpretation is
better than the other on they're actually
what you can.
And so you don't.
And so there's no such in a sense,
there's no reliable judge
of quality literature.
It's arbitrary.
Well,
artificial intelligence people bond at
the same time trying to make machines to
proceed the world.
It turns out the borders between things
are so easily drawn when we look at the
world and I can see your own blind spots,
no effort on my part.
I just see it.
But you know,
there's three and a half billion
years of evolution when into that.
It's an easy problem,
I can solve it,
but not because of any
particular color than mine,
right?
I'm the beneficiary of all this
adds and all the selection.
When they did that for three and a half,
building your process,
that doesn't mean it's easy.
It wouldn't have taken old.
That gap and all those years to manage
it was easy because it very large number
of ways of interpreting rope.
That does not mean that there's a very
large number of ways of interpreting the
world and that's where the
postmodernists gone seriously wrong.
So because think about the constraints
that the one you with regards to how you
have to improve the world.
First of all,
you can't just sit there
or you'll suffer and die.
So you have to go out there and act
in the world and that means there's,
there's problems.
You have to solve it or basically
grounded in your motivational structure.
You know,
you have to eat,
you have to find water,
you have to find shelter,
you have to regulate your temperature.
You have to play with others.
You have to find a mate.
You have to.
You have to pursue something that
produces a certain amount of positive
emotional pain,
don't want to be anxious like and you
don't like you coming quit with all of
those systems and also for your attention
and so you have to address those
issues or or things that are critical
Disney for you when it's worse than so not
only are you are you governed by those
biological God's let's say and are in
some sense they're there,
but you have to figure out how to address
those problems today because you're
not just going to be around today.
You're going to be on today,
tomorrow,
next week and next month.
We're now in five years from now,
10 years from now,
so whatever solution
you come up with today,
which might be,
let's draw the bank,
has the word down the
road and let's rob a bank.
Mike worked quite nicely
today and next week,
but as a five year strategy,
it's a problem with the idea of the one.
We know that because you can say,
well,
don't be an impulsive.
Well why not?
Well,
because it's medium to longterm strategy.
That's.
That's why it doesn't work very well.
Polarization
in society,
and I think the universities are
degrees and I think it's partly
because the intelligentsia isn't west,
has never prompted to
come to terms with their
listening complicitness in it.
What happened in radical
left societies be sorted out
and
published lubricant.
It became for a time completely
unacceptable to profess intellectual
admiration for the Marxist doctrine,
but and I think what happened in France,
the French intellectuals,
the people who dominate the particularly
pathological end of the social sciences
and the humanities in the university
has played the sleight of hand and
transformed them that now ultimately
toxic Marxism into the current theories of
identity politics playing out in front
of us where the proper we to look.
The world is the war against every
other group with a narrative,
the whole pressure,
oppressor and victim,
and that leads nowhere.
Good
on the left leads to exactly
leads to college campuses
that are so repressive.
Premiums will go tell jokes.
They're in more a good thing because
the tyrant is definitely someone who
doesn't like Comedians,
especially as they're making fun of
you because especially if you have any
authority because maybe they'll remind
you of why you're going and you went into
attire and that would be a
good thing to be developed.
We hope for as your level of
authority increases the west,
that's where you want to hit this real
subjective experiences
like meeting are real.
It's not a strong theory
about as far as I'm concerned,
I think that you can make a very
strong case and I think you could make
scientific case for this as well.
That meaning is an extension of the sense
of need and invalid when you're doing
something worthwhile is actually the
most profound to instinct that you have.
It's the most reliable thing there is.
It's the most real thing.
I spent quite a bit of time studying how
the brain works and you have instincts
that orient you towards learning
a very fundamental instinct.
This is called the orientee,
reflexively discovered by Russian
neuropsychologist back in the 19 sixties.
You Orient towards things that surprise
you and that's what opens the door to
learning and you can optimize
that process of learning methods,
zone of proximal development,
but therapists,
Zocor or something like that,
and it's an indication that
you're living on the edge.
On the edge is where secure.
Stabilize yourself
out there.
Don't understand.
It's an exciting place to be a lecturer
and meaningful place in the region.
It's a meaningful place.
That's actually where you should be.
You're secure,
you're practicing what you don't,
but you're getting better at it over time.
It's a place where your adaptation in
the real sense is expanding at an optimal
rate.
It's a place where you're offering so
you're going to be in a way that suits
you,
read to the future in a way that's going
to be good for your family when it's
going to be good for your community.
So all these things stack up.
Harmonious sense of meaning tells you
when you're orienting reflects that helps
you identify where you should be standing,
wherever you are,
wherever you should be communicating,
listening,
wherever you are.
If you pay attention to that
advertisement in meaning been,
first of all,
you have meaningful life,
which is a very useful thing,
but secondly,
you are exactly where you
should be right here now,
so that's a good thing to note too,
because the meeting madness
certainly have pain as a meeting.
I know this trick of argument.
You're so fucking bad.
It's not very useful,
so we can certainly establish that.
Maybe you
might say,
well,
what about the meetings that help
you transcend the pain and suffering?
Turns out they are the
most critical thing.
What looks like to
me about the whole week in front of the
idea I'm facing the and restructuring
was her own reflections of the same.
The idea of facing the dragging
until people like all of that,
almost ancient heroic ideas and ideas
that are associated with an emergent
ethnic girl.
Variants of the same thing.
Girl,
our attempts to picture what it would
be like to be the proper human being.
Religious stories heard attempt,
but if you were ever thinking it could be,
what would you be like?
Oh,
it's pretty complicated because
you're really complicated.
All we can get images and stories,
but what might be like,
we can't articulate it fully,
what were you,
what we all need to be in that because
it's the thing that will redeem us from
the house
and so
on.
A roll.
No,
this isn't just a battle between two
arbitrary ways of interpreting the world.
One of those ways is wrong.
It's the
wrong.
You just leads to catastrophe
rounded property infrastructure,
reality,
but the idea of individual who bears the
burden of being property faces his or
her suffering in front school level,
who faces the unknown
restructures society would.
It becomes tyrannical at ethic of
fair play and courage that's deep.
The were oriented towards.
It manifests itself in
our instinct for it.
It allows us to live with ourselves,
the clear conscience,
able to everything we have
accepts our social world,
right?
And keeps us a good distance away from.
And that's what we could do
and that's where we need to be
thanked
for just a second.
Just to stretch his legs.
Friends,
the job where you're going
to take care of shit.
Now
you're hiring
somebody.
All right,
so here's what we're gonna do,
so we're going to do a q and a,
so you guys submitted questions and
there's literally hundreds here,
which I picked out some of the best ones.
I've actually loved the into
Jordan's computer right now,
which means I could jump on twitter
and end this whole fucking thing
quite close.
Alright,
so we're going to do
a little q and a here.
Everyone feel good?
We're all good.
Thank you
Jordan.
Thank
you first because this is a 10th
or 11th and I'm not kidding.
When I tell people you are different every
single month and is that part of your
plan?
Know
pretty good
audience because then you
can see what you're saying.
Makes Sense.
That's the whole,
that's the secret of free speech in some
stamps strength because that's how you
think.
It's just the thing
to see what we're thinking.
We're going do that by communicating
with people and seeing what happens when
you see where the consequences are.
I've been in a battle
in some sense in Canada
with people who are
so they're so careless that they think
it's okay to introduce legislation that
restricts people's.
Asked me to communicate
like I don't get that.
It's a sin
to this political debate,
let's say,
but it's not political
as far as I'm concerned.
What's happened is that the politicians
did something that wasn't political
thing jumped outside of
their proper domain of,
of activity.
It was like they went down
to the constitutional level
or even lower than that,
so.
Well,
it's okay.
You can mess around with this.
It's like it's not okay.
You're not gonna.
Justify telling people what did they can
say on the ground with some fictitious
compassion,
freedom nonfic dishes to passion for that.
First of all,
thank you.
Don't,
because you're kind of predict the supreme
court ruled that compelled speech was
unconstitutional.
Thank you.
How do you remain so calm in the face
of overwhelming close mindedness?
I don't know.
If I do.
I'm probably.
There are much less than
would appear in public,
so my family,
my wife who's hiding
somewhere in the audience.
Thank that.
I have pretty good support network is
very much with being on this kids or
parents
or friends around me watch
me going through all this
and criticizes me when they
think it's necessary,
know,
have all of this clinical
experience that helps you.
When I talk with Katherine Newman and
she.
She
sat down and talked to her
when the cameras were off.
She was quite friendly and then the
counters when she was a whole different
person and I saw that
don't be thinking you
don't
know
what's going on here,
but it just.
So I just watched her and I
figured out almost immediately that
whoever she was interviewing for no
resemblance to me.
Interesting.
Talking to journalists and I think the
New York Times article is a good example
of that was that was a strange experience
because the young woman who wrote that
article,
she hung around with me for about
two days and she was in my house,
my house when she called
the Chamber of horrors,
which
does have some rough in because
she was.
She was very friendly,
very open to it.
I'm very supportive and engaged and
apparently during that was true and
he might say,
well,
why bother talking to journalists and
that sort of thing happens is first of
all,
it doesn't happen all the time by many,
many journalists.
It's like 200 newspapers in Canada a
year ago came up with support what it was
doing,
so you have to keep the map.
The good.
Can't complain about that,
but more importantly,
I think it's not so bad.
People revealed their hands.
If you talk to people
and watched and listen,
then they revealed your hands so
everyone can see what they're playing and
that's happened to me
40 times.
Probably maybe more in the last two years.
People come after me and say,
well,
you must be this
incarnation of a saint
tammany figure your way.
That's not true
and what's happening in various that it's
been harder on the journalists than on
me and I'm not calling people to continue.
In fact,
I have good friends who think that
the New York Times basically some as a
respectable figure,
but I'm actually concerned
with being respectful.
So you're saying if you
want to sleep with tech,
you could ask one question.
Alright.
I'd like to ask them how you
figured out what I figured out
things
incalculably intelligent.
You know,
when I read,
I read everything he wrote in the 19
nineties about stuff wasn't like I
understood all of it because it's tough
going and I've just done to figure out
how he can figure out what you did.
Maybe you have maybe you know,
people do one in a billion.
No,
maybe it was one in a billion so he could
see things that I can't figure out how
anyone
see
if you have a gift for imagination,
you know,
some people are very good at articulation,
every good thinking in words and some
people are good at thinking in pictures
and he seemed to be really good at both.
You know,
we had a tremendous advantage.
Dream essentially infant learn how to
do that and seem to learn all sorts of
things from his weekend dreams.
If I can do that little bit.
Sometimes when I'm doing
therapy with people,
for example,
I'll be listening to the clinical picture
of my head or a little fragment of the
story.
No,
what country it comes with,
imagery and it's sort of in background
and then I'll notice it and then I'll
tell them,
look when you said that this
happened in my imagination,
we can take apart the relationship between
what they said and what happened in
my imagination that usually ship
substantial light on what's going on.
But he was an absolute master at that.
So I do.
I find out from him how he managed
that and maybe you could say it,
but I sure like to know
I've met anyone like that.
So there were a couple of questions
here asking you to clarify.
It's forced.
Phenomenal.
Should we bust out their phones
for this one recording of this?
If you can do it in two minutes
and we'll throw it up on twitter.
Yeah.
You guys want to punch out your phones
for this one just so we get some video
with your answers for the
enemies respond well to.
So I'll,
I'll ask the question.
So the question is,
what do you mean by
force without doing well?
We could start by saying,
don't be.
I don't mean taking innocent women at
gunpoint and happy over to useless man
accusation.
It was really interesting
to watch that unfold.
What I meant was that monogamy as,
uh,
as something that's socially valued is,
appears to be essentially
a human universal.
That doesn't mean that human beings are
universally monogamous because officers,
we're not serially monogamous in.
Some people have multiple
partners and all of that,
but here's a strong proclivity across.
No society can tilt towards monogamy
and the enforcement is social norms.
Think about it and I can't
believe that I have to say this
just gets buried.
And he comes home and he says,
Dad,
I've been screwing around.
Know
you're not happy about that.
And he doesn't count because he knows
you're not going to be happy about it.
And that's the fourth monogamy.
It's part of the social structure.
It's like what?
It's like.
Well,
most people want a monogamous relationship
and if they enter into a relationship
with someone,
they're not happy.
If that person goes to the surround view,
he would be happy.
If that happens.
That's part of enforced.
It's part of this moment and you
might have noticed the problem.
Get polygamy is actually illegal.
You.
It's
be known for 100 years after most
of whom are left leaning by the way,
because that's how it goes.
That monogamous social structures
are one of the ways we keep children
raised property so that they have a
relatively stable environment and then you
keep male aggression,
especially the aggression of young men
under some degree of social control.
It's not a mystery.
The fact that I got in trouble for
that is it's kind of a miracle foot
notice that worth it.
Like almost every way.
The same thing happens all over the world
and alternative diverse societies and
then when we deviate from that,
there's a price to be paid so and so.
That's why like I'm a New York Times
pariah is because I think the minority all
things considered is a good idea.
Thank
you.
So
do you have any advice for someone who
correctly identified versus a bad choice
but has difficulty following
through
Christ
to someone
who is white?
It's harder to do the right
thing off that because of
the precedent for the future is
the sacrificial gesture to do
sacrifice and so interesting.
It's one of the things I about quite
a bit in promos to figure that out.
I'm really happy about that,
that I sent them ritual sacrifice.
You know,
you read a book sacrificial rituals,
what those people up to,
no burden.
It's like
one of the most fundamental discoveries
that human beings ever made.
It's absolutely unbelievable that we
figured out that you can sacrifice
something of value in the president,
gain something of value in the future.
That's the future,
right?
That's the delayed gratification
scaffold on which context,
thanks
before we can understand it,
and so that's what those
rituals were about,
was acting that out for thousands
of years before we can say,
well,
what sort of sacrifices
did your parents think?
And here's what we know,
what the sacrificial is.
So it's difficult to sacrifice the present
for the future because it means the
foregoing of gratification,
you know,
you need to be gratifying now,
have some water now.
You have to have sex now,
but for the future is also we'll.
So you have to learn how to balance
the future was the precedent.
That's hard.
And I would say,
well you do that the same way.
If you do that for yourself,
the same what you do for a child
that you care for it is that you,
you,
you discipline yourself gently.
And the way you do that is by setting
yourself tasks that are hard but possible.
You know,
you have to get up in rule four,
I think it is.
Compare yourself with who you
were yesterday and with some,
with someone else's today,
it's like what you want to do is be a
little better than you were yesterday.
And you might say what's a little bit,
well,
it has to be announced so that
you're happy if it happens,
but not so little,
but it's a trivial accomplishment.
And then he kind of calibrated.
It's like you know,
you're not interested in playing a
game that you can win every time.
You're kind of a full,
under no circumstances do you want to
have a pretty decent shot at winning,
but maybe that your skill
improves while you're playing it,
so that's what did you set
yourself a task and think,
well,
I can probably in this,
it's a little bit outside
of my zone of comfort.
Let's say it's a little bit
of white habitual practice,
but I think I can do it tomorrow.
I can do it for a week,
and then if you can't do it while they
lower your sights a little bit now,
lower your sights,
tell you a little better,
then you think,
oh,
there's my zone.
I can I can improve at this rate.
You'll find that that's
a meaningful place to be.
It wouldn't be at the place where you
could improve a little bit constantly and
you can find that experiment
that takes humility,
right?
Jennifer,
because you're not as good at
getting better as you think you.